investors continuing to digest headlines
and images of violence in the Middle
East and Malaysian air crash site in
Ukraine but the SP is still trading
around those record highs fresco storage
black rocks global chief investment
strategist rights in the Financial Times
this morning for the most part much of
the global unrest this year has not been
directly linked to near term economic or
earnings growth and as such should have
little significance for the global
economy so what does dr. doom think
about that Marc Faber managing director
of investment firm Marc Faber limited
and publisher of the gloom boom & doom
report joins me now dr. Farber it's
great to have you here I don't think
about that that there's no near-term
economic impact so we're not seeing any
kind of fall out in the market well i
would say that at the present time the
news is always viewed as positive
because even bad news implies that the
feds and other central banks will print
more money and we are in a bubble in a
bubble people are optimistic there is
euphoria are about prices going higher
and so forth and that may be possible
the question is are stocks good value
and I don't think that US stocks are
particularly good value if you look at
price-to-book if you look at the market
capitalization as a percent of the
economy is now at the second highest
it's ever been the highest was in two
thousand and each time when the market
cap as a percent of the economy was this
high it ended in tears but Roger Farina
you've been calling for a correction on
the SP since 2012 you're still calling
for that thirty percent correction but
we keep not getting it why do you think
this time might be different well it is
correct I called for a correction after
having been positive about equities
since 2009
when the S&P was at 666 and I think the
reason why stocks keep on going up is
the excess liquidity that is being
created by the feds and other central
banks around the world it's not because
of a brilliant global economic outlook
as you know the economy in the u.s. is
growing at the very slow pace at very
best it depends how you translate the
economic data that the government is
publishing into reality number two the
European economies are hardly growing
and in emerging economies we have
evidence and I repeat we have the
evidence that there is a meaningful slow
down now most of the economic growth in
the world came from the growth in
emerging economies right post-crisis in
2008 so if those economy slowed down it
won't be very good for corporate profits
does that mean dr. favorite across the
board would you be shorting than US
equities European equities as well as
emerging market equities well when you
have a Fed printing money like crazy and
if the market dropped twenty percent
they would probably increase the asset
purchases it's dangerous to short stocks
but we have a lot of stocks that have
already gone down twenty to forty
percent number two where you always
accuse me that I was calling for a
correction I think they may not be a
correction until they'll be a more
significant decline and be since
november of last year has been calling
for gold to rally and especially for the
very depressed gold miners to rally and
so where the SNC is up seven percent for
the year go
become heading for 10 but gold is still
down more than thirty percent since 2011
though it seems like was that a bubble
has the gold bubble already burst at
this point that is the view of some
people and the majority of investors and
strategists are all the berries about
goals but in my view given all the
uncertainties that we have all the money
printing that we have all the worsening
geopolitical conditions that we have I
think investors should own some gold and
the gdxj the junior gold mining index is
up over forty percent this year well
thank you so much Martha but we really
appreciate it and your insight onto a
potential correction in stocks and of
course i'll look into gold and gold
miners as a way to play that Mark barber
limited and gloom boom & doom report
with one and only dr. Markov